Jedes Loch ist ein einziger Teil der Information. Und die Information oder Daten über jedes Schraubenspieler werden über die Computerwarnung von Magnetikpapier oder Magnetikpapier geteilt.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und nach einer viel zu langen Pause geht es hier endlich mal wieder weiter mit der 193. Ausgabe von diesem kleinen Gesprächsformat. Und ganz standesgemäß habe ich mich auch mal wieder in den Express gesetzt und die Stadt verlassen und befinde mich jetzt in München mit einem, ja einem nicht ganz so frischen Gesprächspartner, weil den hatte ich schon mal, allerdings in einem anderen Format, nämlich bei Raumzeit. Und ich begrüße Klaus Landzettel, hallo.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, wir haben uns ja schon mal über Roboter unterhalten. Und bzw. konkret über Robotik in der Raumfahrt. Und er nahm das Gespräch schon am Anfang schon so eine Richtung, wo ich mir dachte, da müsste man eigentlich auch noch mal drüber sprechen. Und genau das soll jetzt eigentlich auch ein bisschen das Thema sein. Ist jetzt eigentlich gar nicht so klar fokussiert, aber du bist ja noch mal eine Dekade früher mit Computern in Verbindungen gekommen als ich zum Beispiel. Ich bin auch schon nicht mehr der Jüngste. Wann ging das so genau richtig los? Also ich meine, wann hast du die erste digitale Begegnung?
Ja, die erste Begegnung, die war kurz nach dem Studium. Dann bin ich nach Oberpfaffenhofen gegangen und wurde da das erste Mal mit einem Rechner konfrontiert. Die hatten damals im Institut einen Hanniwell-Rechner. Ich glaube, da hieß FP850 oder so, kann mich an den Typ nicht genau erinnern. Aber das war auf jeden Fall der erste Computer, den ich zu Gesicht bekam. Und zum Einstieg fragte mich damals mein damaliger Chef, ob ich einen Plotter reparieren könnte.
Wann war denn das eigentlich?
Das war 1970. Und ich wusste damals noch nicht, was ein Plotter ist. Ich wollte natürlich gleich beim ersten Mal nicht mehr die Blöße geben, zu sagen, ich weiß nicht, was das ist. Aber ich sagte, klar, kann ich reparieren, das Ding? Ich habe mir dann das Handbuch mitgenommen und abends in meinem Zimmer, das ich damals gemietet hatte, hier in der Gegend.
Was muss man sich... also damals war ein...
Das war ein XY-Plotter. Genau, da wurde ein Millimeterpapier eingespannt und da konnte man Zeichnungen darauf ausgeben. Oder auch schreiben. Je nachdem, wie man das Ding angesteuert hat. Und da war ein Fehler in der Ansteuerelektronik. Und ich habe mich dann soweit eingearbeitet, bis ich das Ding dann irgendwann mal erstmal den Fehler lokalisieren konnte und dann reparieren.
Fehler im Sinne von, ist das was kaputt gegangen oder es war schon immer kaputt?
Nein, es ist kaputt gegangen. Es war in der Ansteuerelektronik ein Transistor kaputt. Und ich habe mich dann an die Vorlesung erinnert, wie funktioniert ein Transistor. Das wurde uns anhand der Röhre, der Triode, erklärt. Und ich habe mich dann so reingehangelt in die Elektronik und das Ding letztendlich zum Laufen bekommen. Wir haben es dann wieder angeschlossen und das Ding konnte plötzlich blotten. Das war aber, wie gesagt, an diesem Honeywell Computer. Der hatte auch einen Kernspeicher hinten drin, in dem haben mal Ameisen genistet. Und wir haben uns immer gewundert, warum das Ding Rechenfehler gemacht hat. Einfach weil die Temperatur angestiegen ist. Und da hat dann halt einfach Unfug gerechnet. Aber man muss sich den Rechner eigentlich anders vorstellen als heute. Den konnte man nicht einfach einschalten.
Lass uns mal kurz bei dem Plotter bleiben. Das war ja damals auch schon extrem exotische Geräte. Es gab ja sowieso nichts aus dem Regal. Wie groß war dieser Plotter? Das war so ein Monster-Teil.
Ja, der war so 80 Zentimeter und 30, 40 Tief. Und relativ schwer auch.
Aber im Prinzip musstest du die Elektronik auf der niedrigsten Ebene, auf der niedrigsten Schaltlogik beheben, um das Ding wieder zum Laufen zu kriegen. Also wenn man heute die Dinger einfach gleich wegschmeißen würde.
Damals war das alles diskret aufgebaut mit Transistoren, Dioden und Widerständen und Kondensatoren. Also so integrierte Schaltkreise wie 7400 so nennt und Endgatter und so was, das war damals gerade im Common-Disc, war in den Elektroniken noch nicht verbaut. Und auch die Platinen, die Computer-Platinen, die waren diskret aufgebaut zum Großteil. Und erst später...
Also diskret, muss man glaube ich mal erläutern, heißt, man hatte nicht so einen Chip, auf dem irgendwie alles zusammen gegossen war, auf so einem Die, wie man das heute kennt, sondern die einzelnen Komponenten, aus denen halt ein Chip besteht, waren da auch als einzelne Komponenten, als Einzelhand angelötet vorhanden.
Die gab es wohl schon, diese 74-00, aber die waren eben noch nicht so stark verbreitet. Das war die Elektroniken, die man da hatte oder mit denen ich da zu tun hatte, die waren immer, wie gesagt, diskret mit einzelnen Bauteilen, Transistoren, Dioden, Widerstände, Kondensatoren, Spulen.
Also diese 74er-Serie, das ist ja so eine ganze Serie von Bausteinen, von Texas Instruments. Jeder Stein hat so eine einfache Logik, die man immer mal wieder braucht.
Genau. Und damit konnte man dann natürlich komplexere Schaltkreise aufbauen. Das war alles so in dieser Zeit gleichzeitig entstanden. Aber wie gesagt, die ersten Computer, das waren riesen Kuchenbleche. Also wenn man da an eine CPU denkt, das waren riesen Platinen, die da drin waren. Und alle Bauteile schön brav nebeneinander angeordnet. Was natürlich den riesen Vorteil hatte, wenn das Ding mal einen Fehler hatte, konnte man mit einem einfachen Logiktester auch eine CPU entstören, wo man heute nicht mehr reinkommt.
Wo man heute auch nicht so richtig die Chance hätte, ob der Komplexität ergeraute.
Ich habe oft mit dem Oszillographen, das war ja damals auch schon ein Hightech-Gerät, mich an die Schaltkreise hingeklemmt und geguckt, welche Takt-Signale laufen da drüber, schalten die Bits dann im richtigen Zeitpunkt und so weiter. Das konnte man damals noch tun. Und das ging sogar so weit, dass man auch Speicherfehler reparieren konnte. Wir hatten dann später einen Rechner, das war von der Firma EAI. Ein Paser 100 hieß der Rechner. Der hatte sage und schreibe 4K, 4 Kilo-Bit-Kernspeicher, aber wirklich Kernspeicher, das waren Magnetkerne, auf Drähten aufgefädelt.
Magnetspeicher, also wir reden jetzt von wirklichen sichtbaren Ringen, die selbst Magnete waren.
Das war so eine Matrixstruktur mit Zeilen und Spalten. Da hat man die einzelnen Kerne adressieren können. Und je nachdem, wenn die ummagnetisiert haben, konnte man dieses Signal feststellen, der Ummagnetisierung, und sagen, okay, das war ein Bit 1 oder eine Null drin.
Und wodurch wurden die ummagnetisiert?
Durch die Ströme, die durch die Zeilen und Spaltenträde gegangen sind.
Und dann, also der Ring selbst hat dann sozusagen seine Magnetisierung geändert.
Deshalb konnte man auch den Computer ausschalten und die Information blieb erhalten. Das war natürlich ein Riesenvorteil.
Das, was man sich dann die nächsten 20 Jahre mühsam wieder hat erarbeiten müssen mit den statischen Steinchen, die wir heute so als SSD vorfinden.
Ja, das gab es damals schon. Das war ein 8-Bit breiter Speicher.
4 Kilo Bit, also 4.000 Ringe waren das dann sozusagen.
Und in jeder Zeile war immer ein Ersatzring drin.
Und das war so eine dreidimensionale Struktur.
Ja, das war eigentlich flach aufgefädelt. Das war auch so ein, ich sag mal, Kuchenblech, großes Teil. Und da konnte man an die einzelnen Kerne auch dran. Und die hatten in jeder Zeile immer einen Ersatzkern dabei. Falls mal einer kaputt geht, konnte man durch Umfädeln das Bit durch den Ersatzkern wieder ersetzen. Das habe ich auch mal machen müssen, weil...
Weil das nicht mehr ummagnetisiert ist?
Ja, da war ein Fehler da und man fängt dann an zu suchen und stellt fest, okay, da lässt sich ein Bit nicht mehr umschalten. Also muss der Kern kaputt sein. Und dann konnte man an die Stelle einen anderen Kern hinfädeln. Und damit war der Computer wieder repariert und konnte weiterarbeiten.
Gab es dann auch so einen Speichertest beim Einschalten, mit dem man irgendwie alles erstmal magnetisiert hat und wieder ausgelegen hat?
Wenn man den selber geschrieben hat, gab es den, ja. Aber es war nichts so, wie man das heute gewohnt ist. Man schaltet einen Computer ein und das BIOS fängt erstmal an zu gucken, sind denn alle meine Geräte da, funktionieren die auch? Das gab es natürlich nicht damals. Und man war froh, wenn das Ding überhaupt mal sich zum Leben erwecken ließe. Und dann musste man ja auch den Bootstrap selber eingeben, weil das Ding ist ja stroh dumm gewesen. Der hatte also nichts gespeichert, sodass er wusste, von wo muss er denn jetzt ein Programm laden? Das musste man ihm im Maschinencode eintippen. Also zum Beispiel bei dem Pacer 100, das war ein 16-Bit-Rechner. Da hat man vorne 16 Tasten gehabt. Dann hat man im Oktalcode den Maschinencode eingegeben. Oktal. Und hinten gab es eine Enter-Taste.
Warum Oktal beim 16-Bit-Rechner?
Das war halt so bei dem Ding. Die hatten das Oktalcode eingegeben. Und das ist ja egal. Man kann sich auch auf ein Hexcode einstellen, aber die hatten nun mal das Oktal...
Das Oktalsystem hatte damals ja noch eine interessante Popularität. Auch C ist ja in der Zeit entstanden. Und auch C hat ja als Standardnotation für Zahlen konnte man halt auch oktale Schreibweise verwenden. Wo man sich mal ein bisschen wundert, wozu braucht man denn eigentlich Oktal, wenn man da immer nur 3-Bit-Mit darstellen kann pro Zeichen? Und man hat ja 8-Bits. Aber die Wahrheit ist, es war ja noch gar nicht so festgelegt, wie viele Bit-Einbite eigentlich sind.
Ja, es gab ja damals auch 12-Bit-Rechner. Es gab ja alles Mögliche. 12-Bit? Und irgendwo ist dann wohl das Oktalsystem. Also es war das erste. Das hatte ich kennengelernt, bevor man mit einem Hexcode irgendwo angefangen hat. Und ich habe im Schlaf diesen Bootstrap eintippen können. Das waren 25 Zahlen, die man reinhauen musste. Und ich konnte sogar den Bootstrap eingeben und nebenbei telefonieren. Also das hat mein Kollege zugeguckt, hat gesagt, was machst du da eigentlich? Ich bin sogar am Telefon gehangen, habe auf der Tastatur rumgehackt, und dann immer wieder die Enter-Taste reingedrückt, und dann lief der Rechner an. Also man muss sich wirklich, wie der Bootstrap heißt, aus dem Sumpf ziehen. Man muss dann erstmal sagen, wo findest du denn zum Beispiel dein Lasergerät?
Das ist die digitale Äquivalenz zum Stenotypisten, der irgendwas mitschreibt.
Also wenn man das tagtäglich, ich weiß nicht, wie oft, mal macht, dann kann man das wirklich im Schlaf.
Also jedes Bit hat quasi eine eigene Tasse. Und was heißt dann im Oktalkode eingeben, wenn man jetzt für jedes Bit eine Tasse hat? Das ist ja eigentlich eine binäre Eingabe.
Du hast immer so Dreiergruppen gehabt, für die drei Bits. Und die hat man eingegeben und dann das ganze Feld eben aufgefüllt. Bis 16 Bit voll waren. Das war so eine Tastatur nebeneinander. Immer solche Gruppen und hinten dran die Enter.
Was heißt eine Gruppe? Also waren das jetzt mehrere Tasten?
Wenn ich mich recht erinnere, waren es vier Tasten nebeneinander. In einer Gruppe und dann wieder vier Tasten und das Ganze mal vier. Für die 16 Bit.
Also hat man doch eine Taste pro Bit gehabt.
Ja.
Aber was muss man dann oktal eingeben?
Ja, im letztendlich gibt man ja diese 16 Bit als Zahl ein. Und das waren aber Oktalzahlen, die die angegeben haben. Also ich kann doch eine…
Das muss man sich erstmal erinnern.
Ja, das ist schon so lange her.
Oktal eingeben heißt ja 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 oder 7 drücken.
Ja, genau. In diesen Bit-Feldern habe ich ja die 6 dargestellt, indem man das Bit der Wertigkeit 2 und das 4 setzt und die anderen 0 lässt.
Gut, dann gibt man es ja binär ein.
Okay. Jetzt sind wir beieinander. Dann ist es einfach binär eingegeben.
Man hat es immer oktal im Kopf notiert.
Ich bin dadurch jetzt durcheinander gekommen, weil es Gruppen waren. Das war in Gruppen aufgeteilt, sodass das überschaubar ist mit den Tasten, damit es das Eingeben leichter macht.
Aber trotzdem, oktal war eine gängige Notierung für die Werte selber, auch wenn man es in dem Moment dann binär eingeben muss.
Richtig, man muss es binär eingeben.
Okay, also eine duale Tastatur. Das war das einzige Interface zu diesem Computer?
Das war das Interface, um den überhaupt mal zum Leben zu erwecken. Und dann gab es damals...
Also, Daten-Eingabe, klar. Und dann gab es eine Enter-Taste. Gab es sonst noch irgendwelche Tasten? Irgendwie so Execute oder so was?
Ja, es gab eine Rantaste. Ich konnte zum Beispiel eine Adresse eingeben. Zum Beispiel damals haben alle Programme bei der Adresse 1000 angefangen. Man konnte also ein Programm bei der Adresse 1000 eingeben. Genau mit dieser Methode, wie man auch einen Bootstrap eingebt.
Diese 1000 ist jetzt oktal notiert, oder?
Ja, genau. Und da gibt man es jetzt rein und schreibt seinen Programmcode rein. Und dann sagt man, Adresse 1000 ran. Und dann hat er das eben ausgeführt. Das war die Primitiv-Methode. Später kamen dann so Lesegeräte dazu, wo man mit Lochstreifen zum Beispiel einen Source-Code erstellen konnte. Da hatte man eine Schreibmaschine nebenan mit einem Lochstreifenstanzer. Und dann konnte man im Bootstrap dem Rechner sagen, er muss den Streifenleser ansprechen, zum Beispiel um einen Assembler zu laden, der dann den Code vom Lochstreifen, den Source-Code holt und assembliert. Danach hat man wieder gesagt, wenn du damit fertig bist, dann lädst du bitte den Linker und baust eine Exe daraus. Dann wurde die Exe automatisch auf die Adresse 1000 geschoben und dann hat man über die Randtaste das Programm starten können. Das war alles ein bisschen umständlich und zeitraubend.
Aber im Vergleich zur normalen Hand-Eingabe war das ja schon die totale Revolution.
Klar, das war ein Riesenfortschritt.
Und wie hat man die Löcher da reingemacht?
Indem man an der Schreibmaschine wie an einer Telex-Maschine geschrieben hat. Man hat einen ganz normalen Text geschrieben, hat den auch auf dem Plattpapier gesehen, hat seinen Programmcode, also richtig Buchstaben. Ja, Move A nach B, Lade die und die Zelle, so einen normalen Assembler-Code. Und nebendran hat diese Schreibmaschine einen Lochstreifen-Stanzer und hat das quasi im Achtlochcode damals reingestanzt.
Also als ASCII.
Und das ging sogar so weit, die Streifen würden ja dann entsprechend lang, wenn man große Programme geschrieben hat. Wenn da irgendein Fehler drin war, hätte man das Ganze ja nochmal schreiben müssen. Und da sind wir hergegangen und haben in diesem Achtlochcode korrigiert. Das heißt, wir hatten uns so eine kleine Handstanze gebastelt, indem man Stellen im Code, wo keine Löcher waren, mit dem Stift durchstechen konnte und die Löcher wieder zukleben konnte mit einem Stückchen Lochstreifen-Tape. So konnte man die Einträge korrigieren, die da drauf waren. Das war natürlich nur möglich, wenn es relativ wenig Änderungen waren. Bei großen Änderungen hat es geheißen, alles nochmal von vorne.
Aber man hätte es ja auch so rausschneiden können und so.
Ja, und dann wie so ein Rucksackprogramm, wie man das normalerweise dann im Speicher einhängt, da reintun. Die allen Methoden waren offen, die haben wir alle verwendet.
Das ist schon so ein bisschen mehr wie der Filmschnitt, auch damals ein Audioschnitt noch lief, wo man so ein Tape geschnitten hat.
Das Problem war nur, dass der Laser oft dann über die Klebestellen gestolpert ist. Also das war nicht so ganz einfach, deshalb haben wir die Methode mit dem Punchen von Hand vorgezogen. Das ging eigentlich immer ganz gut. Nur muss man, einmal erinnere ich mich dran, wir haben die Lochstreifen immer in Papierkörben gesammelt. Wenn die aus dem Streifenstanz herausgekommen sind, haben wir den Papierkorb reinlaufen lassen. Da stand groß drauf, Lochstreifen. Aber die Putzfrau hat wohl nicht gelesen. Und die hat uns mal über Nacht die ganzen Papierkörbe geleert. Und wir standen am nächsten Morgen eigentlich vor dem Nichts. Das Einzige, was wir dann hatten, zum Glück, den auf endlos Papier gedruckten Programmcode. Den mussten wir dann einfach nochmal nachtippen. Anders ging das nicht.
Wobei jetzt also mit Assembler ist das ja schon relativ modern. Da hat man ja dann noch einen richtigen Übersetzer, der so richtige Buchstabencodes in den eigentlichen Instruktionscode umsetzt. Das heißt, so mit Nacktessembler in Zahlen schreiben, da bist du schon verschont worden zu der Zeit.
Nee, das war die Zeit vor den Lochstreifen. Da haben wir wirklich an der Tastatur quasi Maschinencode eingegeben.
Ach so, ja klar, weil da gab es dann gar keine ergonomische Codierung.
Ja, da musste man wirklich den Maschinencode einfach eintippen. Und das war ja auch schon ein Fortschritt. Der Rechner hat einem ja doch letztendlich viel Arbeit abgenommen, und da hat man das in Kauf genommen, im Maschinencode zu sprechen. Und es klingt jetzt erst mal kompliziert, aber wenn man das eine Zeit lang macht, dann denkt man überhaupt nicht drüber nach. Man schreibt die Zahlen hin und weiß, das ist ein Lade-Mir-Zelle-A aus dem und dem Speicherplatz usw. Das hat man dann einfach drauf. Oder Jumps und Go-Tos.
Was ja auch so jetzt eigentlich auch schon klar rauskommt, es gab ja damals einfach so viele Firmen, die Computer gebaut haben, von denen man später überhaupt nichts mehr gehört hat. Also ich glaube, Honeywell ist irgendwann so in den 80ern verschieden. Ich glaube, mit Bull sind die erstmal zusammengegangen.
Genau, Honeywell Bull.
Und die sind dann später auch von irgendeiner Bude gekauft worden, die es auch nicht mehr gibt. Also es war auch alles schon einfach kleine Fische, große Fische.
Richtig, der Rechner hat groß Honeywell Bull drauf. Das war dieser erste Honeywell-Rechner. Der mit den Ameisen im Speicher.
Ja, das musst du jetzt nochmal erzählen. Also in den Core sind Ameisen eingezogen. Und deswegen hat es nicht mehr funktioniert?
Klar, man muss sich das vorstellen. Der Rechner hat unten drunter einen riesen Ventilator drin, um die Kühlung hinzubekommen. Und da sind fliegende Ameisen rein. Das war damals, wir hatten mehr oder weniger eine Baracke stand der Rechner. Und wir haben uns gewundert, warum der nach einer gewissen Betriebszeit immer abstürzt oder gar nichts mehr tut. Und ich habe dann irgendwann mal den Schrank hinten aufgemacht. Man muss sich vorstellen, ein Computer war ein Schrank, mit vielen Platinen drin, dickes Power Supply, Drehstromkabel zur Versorgung. Und da hat sich schon was getan von der Energie her. Und ich habe dann einfach nur so eine schwarze Masse gesehen und dann realisiert, dass das Ameisen sind. Dann habe ich den ganzen Speicherblock genommen und rausgezogen und das rausgestellt, fuhr das Fenster und gewartet, bis die Ameisen weg waren.
Warum haben die sich da alle angesammelt?
Das weiß ich nicht. Irgendetwas hat denen gefallen da drin. Entweder die Temperatur oder das muss wahrscheinlich auch über ein Wochenende passiert sein. Da stand der Rechner. Also irgendwas hat ihnen da behagt.
War auch ein Betrieb über das Wochenende?
Nee, damals wurden die Dinge immer ausgeschaltet. Das hat jetzt viel zu viel Energie gekostet. Also er war aus, wahrscheinlich war das Klima für die Ameisen angenehm. Und als wir dann montags wieder angefangen haben zu arbeiten, dann ging es eben daneben.
Und dann hat er sich quasi überhitzt? Er hat sich überhitzt, ja.
Also sie haben nichts kaputt gemacht. Die haben keine Leitungen zerfressen oder sowas. Die haben einfach einen Wärmestau da drin produziert. Und der Speicher ist so heiß geworden, dass er eben nicht mehr funktioniert hat. Und nachdem die weggeflogen waren, dann haben wir den Speicher wieder eingesetzt und alles war Palette.
Es gab ja damals keinen irgendwie erdenklichen Standard. Also 70er, da gab es irgendein System, was in irgendeiner Form vorherrschend war, außer jetzt vielleicht IBM mit seinen Systemen. Aber es gab also nichts herstellerübergreifendes, sondern ein anderer Computer, ein anderer Hersteller, vollkommen ein anderer Ansatz, ein anderes System, alles anders. Wie schnell konnte man dann von dem einen auf das andere? Also war das der einzige Computer, den es gab?
Das war der einzige, den wir damals im Institut hatten. Damals hatten wir Flugversuche durchgeführt, Messungen in Flugzeugen. Man hat zum Beispiel mit einer kleinen Sportmaschine das Verhalten von einem großen Airliner simulieren können. Das heißt, der Computer wurde dazwischen geschaltet. Zwischen Steuereingaben und Klappenstellungen.
Also jetzt am Boden?
Am Boden, das wurde simuliert. Wie wird das System dann reagieren, wenn man diese Eingaben so macht? Da hat man sich einfach auf dieses System erst mal so konzentriert, dass man damit arbeiten konnte. Wenn man jetzt auf etwas anderes umsteigen wollte, auf einen anderen Rechnertyp, dann hat es mehr oder weniger geheißen, von Anfang an neu lernen. Also auch der Umstieg damals auf diesen Pacer 100, das war etwas ganz anderes. Das war wieder ein ganz anderer Rechnertyp. Der hatte damals am Anfang auch noch Lochstreifen als Eingabegerät. Aber da kam dann relativ schnell ein Computer Terminal dazu, also ein richtiges Display, wo man dann schon auch Text eingeben konnte.
Das ist aber dann schon so ein bisschen die Botschaft aus der Zukunft gewesen, oder?
Ja, das war das absolute High-End so ein Ding.
Texteinanders, reden wir jetzt von einem Bildschirm oder reden wir von so einem Druckerterminals?
Nein, das war ein Bildschirm schon. Es gab die Druckerterminals dazwischen. Also nach den Lochstreifen kamen die Lochkarten, die man dann in so großen Schachteln gesammelt hat.
Die waren praktischerweise nicht so leicht kaputtgegangen.
Klar, die waren besser zu handhaben. Und man konnte auch sehr schön editieren da drin. Man konnte Befehle einfügen, indem man einfach Karten wieder eingesetzt hat. Oder Karten austauschen.
Eine Karte, eine Instruktion.
Richtig. Wir haben dann zum Beispiel viel in Fortran programmiert. Ganze Befehlszeilen einfach austauschen. Oder Programmabschnitte woanders hinsetzen, indem man die Karten einfach rausnimmt und woanders einsortiert.
Und wenn irgendjemand mal so eine Routine, so eine generelle Routine schon fertig gemacht hat, dann hat man so auf dem Pausenhof ganze Stapel von Kärtchen getauscht.
So ähnlich, ja. Man hat die dann kopiert. Also Lochkarten konnte man auch kopieren.
Zeigst du mir deinen, zeige ich dir meinen.
Ja, da hat man einen Lochkarten-Leser, den konnte man so schalten, dass er auch hinten wieder neue Karten druckt. Und damit konnte man das kopieren. Das Schlimme daran war nur, wenn man die Dinge mal aus der Ordnung rausgebracht hat. Also ein Kollege ist mal gestolpert mit der ganzen Kiste in der Hand. Und normalerweise haben die Lochkarten immer rechts oben in der Ecke eine Sequenznummer. Also in der Reihenfolge, wie man die Karten editiert hat. Aber wenn das ein Programm ist, an dem man schon viel geändert hat, stimmt natürlich nichts mehr. Und die sind alle dann im Flur gelegen, die Karten. Und das war natürlich ein Chaos. Wir haben dann alle zusammengeholfen, um das Programm wieder zusammenzustellen.
Ich denke, wir sind fertig. Ich habe noch zwei Karten übrig.
Also das waren die Lochkarten. Das war schon gegenüber den Lochstreifen natürlich ein immenser Fortschritt. Das hat uns das Leben ganz kräftig erleichtert. Und wie gesagt, dann kamen die Schreibmaschinen, mit denen man auch direkt Texte eingeben konnte. Die waren auch mit dem Rechner verbunden, mit einer RS-232-Schnittstelle. Und man konnte einfach reinschreiben, und der Rechner hat dann abgespeichert, was man geschrieben hat.
Die erfolgreichste Schnittstelle überhaupt. Bis heute noch von Bedeutung.
Bei den neuen PCs wird sie inzwischen leider weggelassen.
Ja, aber im embedded-Bereich ist das noch nicht tot.
Nach diesem Text, nach diesen Schreibmaschinen, kamen ebenso die ersten Videocomputer-Terminals. Mit einem Display und einer Tastatur. Und natürlich auch einem Editor. Weil den braucht es ja dann auch. Man konnte einen Editor starten auf dem Rechner. Und man hat dann ganze Befehlseilen immer wiederholen müssen. Das Ding hieß Aetlin von Microsoft. Line-Editor, ne?
Wir reden von dem Microsoft Aetlin.
Nein, das war noch ein Vorgänger. Da hieß aber auch schon Aetlin.
Achso, das hat Microsoft auch kopiert.
Das will ich jetzt nicht behaupten. Auf jeden Fall hieß das Ding Aetlin.
Und mit Aetlin könnte man noch im Prinzip, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, auch an so einem Druckerterminal editieren. Weil er immer nur auf einer Zeile agiert hat.
Das ist genau das Prinzip. Wenn man einen Buchstaben falsch hatte, muss man die ganze Zeile neu eintippen. Aber das hat für uns auch eine Umstellung bedeutet, weil man dann nichts mehr in der Hand hat. Wenn man den ganzen Tag da sitzt und irgendwas eintippt, dann verschwindet das Programm sozusagen auf der Platte am Rechner. Was natürlich voraussetzt, dass der Rechner schon eine Platte hatte damals. Das ist klar, weil die ersten Rechner, die hatten keine Festplatten. Deshalb musste man das Zeug ja immer von Lochstreifen einlesen und dann auf eine Adresse speichern und dann überran das Programm aktivieren. Anders ging es hier gar nicht.
Der Core war ja auch nicht wie eine SSD als Dauerspeicher gedacht, sondern das war ja der eigentliche Arbeitsspeicher, der nur so als Abfallprodukt seinen Zustand einfach breiterhalten hat.
Richtig. Und mit, wie gesagt, 4K war schon die Anfanggröße. Wir haben dann mal erweitert auf 8K, damit wir größere Programme reingebracht haben. Aber das war dann schon ein Riesenspeicher damals. 8K. 8000 Bits. Kann sich heute keiner vorstellen.
800 Bits.
Aber man konnte trotzdem schon einiges damit tun.
Ja, das ist das Erstaunliche. Heute würde man da kein Icon mehr drin abgespeichert bekommen.
Gut, aber das waren alles Assembler-Programme. Ja, also da war noch keine Fortran-Programmierung oder so. Die hatten dann schon so 32k oder auch mehr, 128k.
Aber bleiben wir nochmal bei diesem ganz alten Scheiß. Ich finde ja diese Technologieschritte vor allem auch immer dahingehend bemerkenswert, als dass man heute noch, wenn auch nur an Ansätzen, dann doch immer noch irgendwas davon sieht. Also gerade in einem anderen Podcast unterhalten wir uns immer gerne auch so über Editoren. Und was kommt dann immer wieder hoch? Na ja, EMAX und auch VIM, also VI, ist ja auch noch sehr populär. Aber was dann auch wieder nicht wissen ist, manche wissen nicht, dass VI dann vor VIM kam. Weil VIM ist ja nur der VI Improved. Und der VI heißt deshalb VI, weil er halt der Visual Mode war von einem Zeilen-Editor, der X hieß. Wobei X, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, die Extended-Version von Ed war. Und das war halt alles noch so zeilenorientiert. Also merkt man, wie das alles aus dieser Zeit noch von diesen Druckerterminals nach oben kam. Und auch diese ganze Sprache, die heute in den Zeichensätzen so spricht, diese ganzen Control Sequences, wenn man sich ASCII anschaut, so die ersten 32 Zeichen, bevor es so mit Space und Ed und so weiter losgeht. Carriage Return. Das CR war ja wirklich ein Wagenrücklauf auf dem Drucker. Und der Line Feed ist halt dann, wenn sich die Weiße eine Zeile dreht.
Ja, von daher kam das ja auch. Und auch diese ganzen Zeichensätze, die da drauf waren, so diese Liniengrafiken, die haben wir massenhaft verwendet, um irgendwelche Displays dann auf diesen Computer Terminals anzuzeigen. Also ich habe sehr viel mit Escape-Sequenzen gemacht, um dann so Ausgabemasken zu erstellen.
Also jetzt auf dem Bildschirm.
Auf dem Bildschirm, um ein Display lesbar zu machen, sodass die Zahlen zum Beispiel von einem Flugzeug, von der Flughöhe oder Querlage oder sowas immer am gleichen Platz auf dem Display erscheinen. Das hat man mit Escape-Sequenzen gemacht, indem man den Cursor eben über die Escape-Sequenzen an die Stelle gefahren hat und dann die Zahl gedruckt hat. Und ja, man arbeitet in vielen kleinen Schritten. Heutzutage denkt da niemand mehr nach. Man macht ein Fenster auf und schreibt rein. Und dann nimmt einem Visual Studio oder was immer die Arbeit ab. Aber das musste man damals alles zu Fuß machen. Oder irgendwas einrahmen mit Linien und Eckzeichen usw. Das waren alles ASCII-Zeichen, die man über Escape-Sequenzen dahin platziert hat, wo man sie haben wollte.
ZB die Rahmenzeichen waren ja nie wirklich Bestandteil von ASCII, wir sehen das wahrscheinlich von der oberen Bereich.
Das ist der obere Bereich, die da oben drüber sind. Ja, genau.
Also MS-DOS hat das ja dann später auch noch lange weitergelebt. Also nach dieser ersten Honeywell und EAI-Pace, was ist das überhaupt für eine Firma? Also von EAI habe ich wirklich noch nie gehört.
Soweit ich mich erinnere, heißen die Electronics Associated Incorporated. Also die Vertretung war zumindest in Aachen.
Steht noch nicht mal in der Wikipedia.
Die haben auch Analogrechner gebaut.
Electronics Association Incorporated.
So ähnlich. Also die haben auch Analogrechner gebaut und Hybridrechner. Wir hatten auch einen Hybridrechner im Institut.
Ich habe es gerade gefunden hier. Major Supply of Electrical Analog Computing Equipment 50s und 60s played a major role bei NASA, Space Probe und Satellites. Okay, also das war sozusagen ohnehin in dem Raumfahrtbereich.
Das waren aber wahrscheinlich noch die Analogrechner.
Tr20 und so weiter.
Ja, das waren reine Analogrechner.
So, dann gibt es hier noch ein IAI. 640, 7800, Hüdack.
Die 7800 war, glaube ich, der Hybridrechner.
Scientific Computation System. Hybrid inwiefern war der Hybrid?
Der hat einen Digitalteil und einen analogen Teil. Und die waren zusammengeschaltet. Man konnte also Gleichungen auf dem Analogteil stecken und zum Beispiel auch Parameter über den Digitalteil variieren. Das war eine ganz clevere Sache. Vor allen Dingen ein Analogrechner hat ja den Vorteil, dass er keine Abtastzeiten und Quantisierungen kennt. Wenn die Verstärker genau eingestellt sind, ist das Ergebnis in Echtzeit da. Da muss nichts digitalisieren oder Analogwerte einlesen über einen AD-Wandler und dann mühsam Digitalzahlen umwandeln. Der hat es analog und das Ergebnis ist sofort da. Das Problem dabei war, dass man das Problem, das man lösen musste, skalieren muss, sodass es in den Bereich der Analogverstärker hineinpasst. Das war eigentlich der erste schwierige Schritt, den man lösen musste, dass man keinen Zahlenüberlauf produziert auf dem System.
Aber was haben diese Analogcomputer überhaupt gemacht?
Zum Beispiel der Regler für die DO-31E, das ist dieser Senkrecht-Starter von Dornier. Damals der Professor, den wir in Regelungstechnik hatten, der hat uns diesen Regler auf Analogrechnern stecken lassen. Wir haben wirklich mit Analogrechnern diesen Lageregler damals programmiert, um die DO-31 auch stabil zu halten.
Aber was heißt Analogrechner? Die Berechnungen wurden quasi analog durchgeführt?
Richtig, da sind Verstärker und Abschwächer drin, wo man jetzt Zahlen praktisch durch Spannungen darstellen kann. Und je nachdem, wie man die Ein- und Ausgänge miteinander verschaltet, kann man da ganz komplexe Gleichungssysteme drauf programmieren.
Also mehr als nur Addition und Subtraction?
Ja, die konnten auch differenzieren, indem man ihnen einen Kondensator reingesteckt hat, dann hat er das Differential gebildet und so weiter. Also das war eigentlich sozusagen auch eine super Sache.
Hat auch eine Weile gedauert, bis man das so in digital wirklich komplett wieder abbilden konnte.
Ja, vor allen Dingen mit den Problemen, denen man sich in der Digitaltechnik rumschlägt, die gab es damals nicht. Ich kann ja bei einer Zahl, wenn ich jetzt irgendwas berechne auf dem Digitalrechner, nie genau sagen, ob das Ergebnis denn hundertprozentig stimmt. Durch die Quantisierung rutsche ich ja immer irgendwo dazwischen. Sonst bräuchte ich ja quasi einen unendlich langen Akkumulator, um keine Zahlen abschneiden zu müssen. In dem Moment macht man ja immer wieder einen Fehler beim Digitalrechner. Beim Analogrechner, wenn die Verstärker sauber kalibriert waren, dann hat das Ding sehr genau gerechnet und vor allen Dingen blitzschnell.
Also den Pacer 100, den habe ich jetzt nicht gefunden, aber ich habe ja immerhin einen Pacer, der ist ja wohl nur Pacer und nicht Pacer, 231 R Analogcomputer gefunden. Auch sehr hübsch hier noch mit der klassischen Bediener-Dame.
Die haben ja schon riesen Plattenlaufwerke. Also das muss schon fast eine Nachgängerversion sein.
Aber auch geil. Da kann man sich dann eigentlich nur Star Trek-Personal und Kraftwerk direkt davor stellen.
Die Dinger gab es dann mit Erweiterung dem Pacer. Da gab es dann Floating-Point-Unit dazu. Das war noch ein riesen Schrank nebenan. Auch noch mit einem Stromversorgungskabel.
Aber dann auch digital, richtig?
Das war dann digital.
Floating-Point-Unit. Also die Floating-Point-Unit war quasi noch mal ein Schrank.
Noch mal ein Schrank nebenan. Dem hat man Gleitkommazahlen verpasst und der konnte die verarbeiten.
Also das, was dann so in den Late 80s ein zusätzlicher Chip war, dem man noch neben seiner eigentlichen CPU stecken musste. Und das heutzutage natürlich meistens, zumindest bei den größeren CPUs, einfach Teil des Systems ist, war dann einfach noch mal ein Schrank.
Das war ein Schrank nebendran, ja.
Den man auch noch mal separat programmieren musste, oder konnte den schon verbinden?
Ja, der war verbunden und der wurde über, ich glaube, über einen DMR-Kanal angeschlossen, also Direct Memory Access-Kanal. Und dem hat man vom Haupt-Kernspeicher die Daten dann rübergepumpt. Und der hat die nach einem vorgegebenen Programm eben verarbeitet. Man konnte dann Multiplikation, Addition und so was auf dem Floating-Point-Prozessor durchführen. Und das Ergebnis hatte dann auch wieder auf eine bestimmte Stelle zurückgeliefert im Speicher.
Wie schnell waren denn diese Systeme getaktet?
5 MHz etwa. Das waren dann schon die schnellen. Das hat sich lange Zeit in der Gegend gehalten. Also ich kann mich erinnern, der Floating-Point-Prozessor von dem Pacer war zu weit. Ich weiß, eine 5 MHz Maschine. War schon nicht ganz langsam.
Naja, so schnell konnte man es aufhören, weil jemand nicht mehr selber rechnen.
Das ist richtig, ja. Aber man musste sich halt alles, was man so braucht, dann selber dazubauen. Auch digital analog Ausgabe. Man will ja irgendwas tun mit dem Rechner. Wir haben damals Roboter angesteuert über Analogschnittstelle. Das heißt, eine Spannung, die man ausgegeben hat am Rechner, hat eine bestimmte Gelenkstellung am Roboterarm bedeutet. Und jetzt musste das natürlich auch kalibriert werden. Also das heißt, wenn ich eine gewisse Spannung ausgebe, muss man auch sicher sein, dass die Spannung auch wirklich rauskommt, die man vorher eingegeben hat. Und das hat man eigentlich immer gemacht, indem man morgens Spannungen angelegt hat und mit einem Digitalvoltmeter gemessen hat, stimmt denn das noch? Und wenn nicht, muss man nachkalibrieren. Und das waren wir dann irgendwann mal zu blöd. Die Dinge haben ja auch eine analoge Eingabe. Und ich bin dann hergegangen und habe mir einen Digitalvoltmeter besorgt, das über eine serielle Schnittstelle angesprochen werden konnte. Und das Digitalvoltmeter hing an einem Multiplexer, an dem man dann die einzelnen Analogkanäle aufschalten konnte. Und der hat dann automatisch die Spannungen gemessen und den Messwert an den Rechner zurückgegeben. Und damit konnte man in der Schleife sozusagen die Ausgaben...
Also man hat selber eine Spannung erzeugt und meinte, das müssten jetzt 2,5 Volt sein.
Und wenn es nicht war, dann hat das Messgerät dem Rechner zurückgemeldet, das sind aber nur 2,3 Volt. Und dann hat man dann Korrekturwerte berechnet, damit dann wirklich 2,5 hinten wieder rauskommen. Und das lief dann relativ schnell ab, das Ganze, und hat uns schon mal unheimlich viel Zeit gespart. Aber das waren so Dinge, die man eben selber entwickeln musste. Das gab es nicht zu kaufen. Ich konnte nicht irgendwo hingehen und sagen, ich hätte jetzt gerne so einen Teil, was mir das automatisch kalibriert.
Wie viele Leute wart ihr da, die da um diese Systeme herumsaßen und mitprogrammierten?
Ganz am Anfang, das war so Anfang der 70er, wird man schätzen, so 5, 6 Personen. Die haben Programme entwickelt.
Was war da so das Gefühl? Ich weiß ja noch, als ich mit den Computern in Verbindung kam, da war das schon deutlich weiter fortgeschritten. Mich hat das sofort in Beschlag genommen. Dieses Gefühl, es gibt da eine Maschine, der man sagen kann, wie die Welt auszusehen hat. Auch wenn es nur eine kleine Binärwelt ist an der Stelle, aber die ja in Anfang und Ende hat, wo man dazwischen eben sagen kann, was in welche Richtung zeigt. Mich hat das irgendwie enorm bewegt. Ich wusste zwar am Anfang noch nicht so richtig, wofür das irgendwie gut ist, aber ich wusste auf jeden Fall, dass es für irgendwas gut ist. Da lauerte irgendwie was auf mich. Wie war das für euch? War das nur so schrittweise Verbesserung von irgendwie bestehenden Systemen? Oder hatte man da schon so eine Ahnung, dass da etwas ganz Revolutionäres heranbricht?
Also Letzteres war der Fall. Einfach dadurch, dass man gesehen hat, wie rasant damals trotzdem die Entwicklung vorangegangen ist. Angefangen vom Lochstreifen über die Karte zum Journal und so weiter. Ja, das war innerhalb von ein paar Jahren. Das ist eigentlich sehr schnell gegangen und man war ständig dran, irgendwas Neues zu lernen oder sich auf neue Systeme einzustellen. Und wir haben natürlich schon sehr schnell gemerkt, wie nützlich so ein Computer ist, welche Probleme man blitzschnell damit lösen kann, an denen man mit Rechenschieber stundenlang gekaut hat. Wenn man einmal die Gleichungen eingegeben hat, dann war das Ganze nur auf den Knopfdruck und die Auswertung war da. Also der Vorteil war eigentlich schon sofort erkennbar und mich hat das Ganze wahnsinnig fasziniert. Das ging sogar so weit, dass ich mir mal so einen Computerkurs angetan habe, eben auch noch bei EAI damals in Brüssel. Wie funktioniert der Computer den Innen, die CPU? Das heißt, man hat also nicht auf Assembler- oder Maschinencode-Ebene geguckt, sondern im sogenannten Microcode. Also wenn ich jetzt einen ADDIER-Befehl hatte, wurde der in seine Mikroschritte zerlegt. Adressier mal die Zelle so und so, hol den Wert über den Bus in den Akku, dann nimmst du die nächste Zelle und dann verarbeitest du die beiden. Und das hat bei mir eigentlich dann das Verständnis irgendwie geweckt, wie das Ding überhaupt funktioniert. Weil am Anfang haben wir natürlich einfach hier Maschinen- oder Assemblercode eingegeben, und der Computer macht das schon. Das war zwar eine wesentlich niedrigere Ebene, als man heute mit Computern umgeht, aber für uns trotzdem eigentlich schon relativ abstrakt. Man wusste nicht genau, was macht der Rechner innen drin. Wie löst er zum Beispiel?
Da haben wir die Äquivalenz zum Maus und Fenster.
Richtig, ja. Was macht er, wenn ich hier schreibe, addiere zwei Zahlen? Wie macht er das? Und man wusste natürlich, wie man binär addiert und subtrahiert. Aber wie ist der Computer denn macht intern? Das war nicht so ganz klar. Und das haben wir eben dann auf diesem Kurs gelernt. Und ich war dann wirklich in der Lage, auch mal, als die CPU einen Fehler hatte und falsch subtrahiert hat, im Mikrocode durch den Rechner durchzugehen, zu gucken, welcher Chip ist denn da kaputt? Und damals waren da schon diese und und oder-Gatter und so was, das war dann schon dran verbaut in diesem Rechner. Und da konnte man lokalisieren, dass das, ich weiß nicht mehr, welcher Chip das war, aber das war ganz eindeutig, dass in dem Adierwerk einer der Maillekäfer, die da verbaut waren, kaputt war. Dann konnte man dann austauschen in den Rechner, oder die CPU ging wieder, man konnte CPUs reparieren. Oder auch Plattenlaufwerke, die Lesefehler hatte, selber justieren. Das waren Dinge, da kommt man dran, das war noch Maschinenbau. Eine Platte mit ein paar Megabyte Speicher, die hat so um 30-40 Zentimeter Durchmesser, so eine Aluscheibe.
Hier hängt gerade einer an der Wand.
So was wie hier an der Wand hängt mit diesen Schleifspuren, wo Headcrash nebendran steht.
Und ein schönes Foto von zwei Ziegenböcken, die gerade gehen.
Die Platte habe ich mir deswegen ins Büro gehängt, weil die mir einen Riesenschreck verpasst hat. Ich weiß noch, wir hatten Flugversuche angesetzt. Und ich bin neben dem Computer gesessen, neben dem EAI-Rechner. Und habe am Terminal irgendetwas eingegeben und plötzlich quietscht es ganz laut neben mir. Und da sind die Köpfe auf die Platte runtergekommen, die Schreibleseköpfe. Und dann sind diese Schleifstuhlen, die man jetzt auf diesem Träger hier sieht, entstanden. Das Problem war, dass wir die...
Also wir reden jetzt hier von einer Platte in Schallplattengröße. Ein bisschen größer als eine 33er LP.
Ein bisschen größer. Und von der gab es mehrere Ebenen übereinander. Also es war nicht so, dass so eine Scheibe jetzt die 2 Megabit gepackt hätte, sondern es waren, glaube ich, vier Scheiben übereinander. Da konnte man 2 Megabyte drauf speichern auf so einer Platte.
Es ist eigentlich erstaunlich, dass dieses Prinzip eigentlich bis heute, also jetzt gerade noch so, beibehalten wurde, dass eigentlich diese Magnetscheibe eigentlich eine extrem zukunftsgewandte Entwicklung war. Ich meine, vorher gab es eigentlich nur das Band, oder?
Gab es Band oder die Karten?
Stimmt, die Karten gab es auch noch.
Und danach kamen direkt diese, oder Magnetbänder gab es dazwischen, Magnetbandmaschinen, was natürlich immer ein Riesenthema war, wenn man dann immer von Anfang zum Ende wieder spulen musste. Da gab es BOT, Begin of Tape, EOT, End of Tape und so weiter. Die Marken musste man immer abfragen, wenn man dann vor- und rückwärts gespult hat, automatisch.
Hat es aber auch in den ASCII-Zeichensatz geschafft, solche Sachen.
Jaja, die stehen ja heute noch drin.
Oder nicht, aber Tape, jetzt bin ich gar nicht so sicher.
Ist das Text oder Tape? Begin of Tape, das war hundertprozentig...
Im ASCII? Das ist nicht BOT, das ist nicht im ASCII drin.
Also das war ein Code, den man abfragen musste.
Das ist nicht im ASCII.
Das ist nicht im ASCII drin?
Ich habe es gerade selber verwechselt.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall die Bezeichnung EOT und EOT.
EOT ist nicht End of Tape, sondern das bezieht sich auf Transmission.
Aber zum automatischen Vorwärts-Rückwärtsspulen bei den Bändern gab es genau diese Bezeichnung, die gesagt haben, hier fängt jetzt der Code an, der auf dem Band steht, und hier hört er auf. Ich habe es immer als End of Tape, weil es so naheliegend war. Da war das Tape eben zu Ende. Und wenn das End of Transmission heißt, ist ja fast das Gleiche, da steht, da kommt halt nichts mehr dahinter. Die Platten haben sich gehalten, aber man muss sich mal vorstellen, wie sich das verändert hat im Laufe der Zeit, wie hoch oder wie dicht die einzelnen Spuren jetzt beieinander liegen. Also hier konnte man mit Madenschrauben und vorsichtigem Trimmen mit Schraubenzieher die Schreibköpfe, Schreibleseköpfe über die Spuren justieren. Also nachdem die Platte hier damals runtergekommen war, die Köpfe.
Was sind Madenschrauben?
Das sind Schrauben, die also keinen hervorstehenden Kopf haben, sondern das ist eigentlich nur das Gewindeteil mit einem kleinen Stritt. Und vorne sind die ganz kegelförmig zugespitzen, sodass man, wenn dieser Kegel irgendwo beim Gegenstück eingreift, was linear verschieben kann, je nachdem, wie weit man die Schraube reintretet. Und das waren justage Schrauben, mit denen man die Kopfposition über der Platte variieren konnte.
Damit er wieder schön in der Mitte der Spur ist.
Genau, nachdem dieser Crash passiert ist, hatte ich mir aus Brüssel Ersatzleseköpfe schicken lassen, das weiß ich noch per Express, im Zug. Ich bin dann selber nach München gefahren und habe das Ding am Bahnhof abgeholt, weil wir wirklich wichtige Termine hatten. Ich bin am Wochenende da gesessen und habe dann eine Platte eingelegt, von der ich wusste, die ist in Ordnung. Ich habe die Köpfe über den Daumen hingeschraubt, wo sie ungefähr sein müssten.
Also meint ihr, mit Platte dann mehrere Scheiben?
Ja, das ist eine Scheibe, die man eingelegt hat. Das ist eine Platte mit mehreren Scheiben. Die hatten wir aber komplett reingelegt. Die Köpfe fuhren dann über diese Scheiben drüber. Jetzt ging es darum, die so zu justieren, dass die genau über der Formatierung liegen, wie auf der Platte geschrieben ist. Das hat man dann mit einem Oszillografen gemacht.
Aber man muss ja nicht jedes Mal, wenn man eine neue Platte einlegt, wieder neu justieren.
Nein, nur wenn die Köpfe runtergekommen sind und man tauscht sie. Wenn man die Köpfe ausbauen muss, was man heute natürlich niemals macht bei einer Platte. Aber damals war das schon noch möglich. So ein Plattenlaufwerk hat ja auch etliche tausend DM eingekostet damals. Also es war schon wert, dass man da eine Hand anlegt und versucht, sie zu reparieren.
Also neue Köpfe rein und dann muss man das so machen, dass es auch für dich eine richtige Stelle war. Wie kriegt man das dann raus?
Indem man mit einem Oszillografen das Lesesignal beobachtet und es dann einfach so auf Maximum trimmt und hofft, man ist über der richtigen Spur.
So ein bisschen wie Radiokanal auf UKW-Einstellung.
Ja, so wie Tune und wenn es dann ein schön sauberes Signal gibt, dann weiß ich, also die Köpfe liegen jetzt sauber über einer Spur und da muss man noch gucken, ob er dann auch den Plattenanfang findet. Wenn man versucht auf die Platte zuzugreifen, merkt man das sehr schnell. Wenn das eine Betriebssystem-Platte war, wo dann Start vom Betriebssystem war und er hat nicht gestartet, dann war es klar, ich habe die falsche Spur erwischt, ich muss eine nächste suchen. Und auf jeden Fall nach einem Tag Arbeit hatte ich die vier Köpfe insgesamt justiert und die Platte lief wieder. Etwas, was man heute niemals mehr machen kann.
In welchem Jahr befinden wir uns jetzt eigentlich gerade, wo die Festplatten kamen?
Das war 1975, 1976. Da hatten wir sie hier. Also wir haben ja immer nach Erleichterungen gesucht, um von dem Papierkram wegzukommen. Und damals war es ja auch noch so, dass man sein Programm-Listing irgendwo haben wollte. Man musste das ja auch ausgeben. Da gab es die Zeilendrucker. Ich weiß nicht, ob dir das noch was sagt. Das sind Drucker, die mit einem Schlag eine ganze Zeile drucken. Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, mit einem Schlag eine ganze Zeile drucken. Damit konnte man Musik machen, indem man sich ausgeguckt hat, wenn ich eine ganze Zeile A's z.B. gedruckt habe, dann hat das richtig gemacht. Weil dann 132 Charakter in die Zeile reingepasst haben, auf einen Schlag zuschlagen. Das hat das ganze Ding vibriert. Man konnte einfach durch Buchstabenkombinationen anderen Sound erzeugen im Line-Printer. Dafür war er natürlich nicht gemacht. Das war nur so ein Nebeneffekt, wo man den Spieltrieb einfach freigeben konnte.
Das ist interessant. Jetzt sind wir wieder bei meiner Frage von vorhin. Was habt ihr euch für Gedanken gemacht über die Computer als solche? Abhängig davon, dass sie total nützlich waren, diesen Spieltrieb zu entwickeln, das teilen alle Gruppen, die sich damals mit Computern auseinandergesetzt hatten. Was ging dir damals durch den Kopf? Was war deine Erwartung, wie sich das so entwickeln würde? Jetzt wissen wir natürlich, wie sich das entwickelt hat. War das alles absehbar für dich?
Nein, das war es auf keinen Fall. Das war nicht absehbar. Wir haben immer gehofft, dass die Computer irgendwann mal leichter und kleiner werden. Denn ein Computer hat ja bedeutet, ich brauche einen eigenen Raum, ich brauche eine Klimaanlage, ich muss ständig runterkühlen, weil sonst geht er kaputt. Die verbrauchen jede Menge Energie, die Dinge. Und es war schon immer so ein Traum, dass das irgendwann mal kleiner werden müsste. Ansonsten war eigentlich klar, dass ein Computer schon etwas sehr Nützliches ist und dass der mit Sicherheit nicht verschwinden wird in nächster Zeit, sondern dass sich das weiterentwickeln wird. Das war eigentlich klar, weil der Fortschritt war einfach da. Man hat fast jeden Monat wieder was Neues gelesen, was es denn gibt. Dann kamen alle möglichen Bauteile auf den Markt, die man dann an Computer anschließen konnte. Und man konnte den Einsatzbereich der Computer kontinuierlich erweitern. Also man hat schon gesehen, dass die immer breiter sich quasi im Leben ausbreiten in der Anwendung. Und es kam ständig was Neues dazu.
Was dachtest du, wohin es führt?
Ich hätte niemals gedacht, dass es so weit führt, wie es jetzt ist. Das war gar nicht vorstellbar. Dass man diese Rechenleistung, die man heute in einem Handy hat, das hatte früher kein Rechenzentrum gehabt. Und ein Rechenzentrum war schon ein Erlebnis, so ein Ding mal zu sehen. Mit riesengroßer Saal, mit tausend Schränken, wo sich nur Platten gedreht haben, um die Daten zu speichern. Das war ja alles Maschinenbau. Und die haben ja riesen Motoren drin, um die Platten überhaupt mal auf Drehzahl zu bringen. Das war ja nicht so, dass das so ein kleines Laufwerk war, sondern da wurde wirklich Energie verheizt und ständig. Deshalb hatten die auch alle Drehstromanschlüsse. Und das war für mich schon so ein Erlebnis. Ich habe irgendwann mal mit dem Z80 zu tun. Da haben wir so eine Steuerung für eine Faserwickelmaschine geschrieben. Und das war ein Riesenschritt. Also von so einem großen Schrank plötzlich auf einen kleinen Maikäfer runterzugehen.
Der Zilog Z80 war ja eigentlich so einer der ersten Mikroprozessoren, die dann später ja auch schon so eine Homecomputer-Generation mitgeträgt haben. Insbesondere die Sinclair Computer aus England.
Und wir haben den verwendet zur Maschinensteuerung in Verbindung mit einer AMD. 9511 ist das Ding, glaube ich. Das ist ein Floating-Point-Coprozessor. Das war eigentlich eine ganz geschickte Sache. Man konnte da ziemlich komplexe Systeme auf dem Z80 in Verbindung mit der AMD Floating-Point-Unit lösen. Man konnte der APU einfach über Register quasi Zahlen reinschreiben, die sie dann als Leitung...
Was ist die APU?
Arithmetic Processing Unities, das Ding, glaube ich.
Ah, man versteht die. ALU.
Oder ALU.
Dann nennt man sie normalerweise ALU.
ALU oder APU. Oh, das ist schon so lange her. Das kann beides sein. Also ich kenne es eigentlich nur unter AMD 9511. Und die hatten wir da neben dem... Okay, und die hat man über zwei Arten, soweit ich mich erinnern kann, adressieren können. Einmal, indem er in so 8-bit-weise die Zahlen drüber geschrieben hat, im Speicherbereich, oder auch über DMA ganze Bereiche übertragen. Und das war eigentlich eine geschickte Sache. Man konnte da sehr viel und sehr schnell damit rechnen. Ich kann mich erinnern, ich habe einmal eine Anwendung geschrieben, wo wir diese 9511 an einem zweiten Z80 angeschlossen hatten, den man ganze Gleichungssysteme programmiert hatte. Also ich hatte eine Gleichung, die hatte eine Nummer. Und ich habe jetzt gesagt, ich schicke dem zweiten Z80 mit dieser ALU eine Gleichungsnummer und die Eingangsparameter. Dann hat er diese Gleichung berechnet und das Ergebnis kam dann wieder zurück mit der Gleichungsnummer davor, sodass ich immer wusste, zu welcher Gleichung gehört denn das Ergebnis, was der mir gerade im FIFO hinten wieder übergibt. Und damit konnte man fast eine Art Parallelrechnen betreiben. Also wenn ich weiß, ich habe schon alle Parameter zusammen, die ich brauche, um einen komplexen Vorgang zu berechnen, dann habe ich die rübergepumpt auf diesen Number-Cruncher, wie wir das Ding genannt haben, und dem die Gleichungsnummer gegeben, da hat er schon mal angefangen zu rechnen. Und die erste CPU konnte in ihrem eigenen Prozess weiterlaufen. Und wenn man das geschickt gemacht hat, dann waren die Ergebnisse immer rechtzeitig da, sodass der nächste wieder drauf zugreifen konnte. Und damit konnte man sehr viel Zeit einsparen. Und das war eben das, was bei Maschinensteuerung ja immer reinschlägt. Ich muss in die Erstzeitbedingungen einhalten. Ich darf nicht aus meinem Takt rauskommen, sonst fliegt mir die ganze Maschine um die Ohren. Und wir haben damals so eine Faserwickelmaschine betrieben. Ich glaube, das war ein 20 Meter langes Bett. Das ist ähnlich wie eine Drehbank, eine lange, bei der der Schlitten vom Computer gefahren wird. Also die Spindel dreht mit einer bestimmten Geschwindigkeit.
Also Faser, wir reden jetzt von...
Kohlefaser.
Kohlefaser, um so Seile zu bauen oder Verbundstoffe.
Ja, um zum Beispiel einen Wassertank zu wickeln. Es gibt ja so Tanks, die man mit Kohlefaser wickelt. Später ist man auch dazu übergegangen, mit Carbonfaser, Hubschrauber, Rotorblätter zu legen. Die werden natürlich dann nicht gewickelt. Dann fährt die Maschine über so ein Bett und legt die Fasern rein. Und diese Berechnung, diese Vortriebsgeschwindigkeit in Relation zur Spindelgeschwindigkeit, das haben wir auf dem Z80 mit der ALU zusammengerechnet. Und wenn man sich vorstellt, man hat so einen kleinen Rechner, einen kleiner Z80, und steuert damit eine riesen Hydraulikmaschine an, mit einem 20 Meter langen Bett. Das ist schon ein seltsames Gefühl, dass man mit so einem kleinen Rechner so riesen Dinge bewegen kann.
Bevor wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr in diese Mikroprozessor-Generation eingehen, weil das war ja dann im Prinzip so die eigentliche Revolution der 70er Jahre, dass man eben genau von da, wo wir eigentlich angefangen haben, nämlich alles war diskret aufgebaut, es gab kaum integrierte Schaltungen, also es gab schon welche, aber es war noch nicht unbedingt üblich, sie so zum Einsatz zu bringen, weil dann war das halt zu dem Zeitpunkt der neue heiße Scheiß, dann zunehmendermaßen eben integriertere Systeme, die ja dann letztlich auch zum Bau der ersten Kleinstcomputer führten, so für den Hausgebrauch, die dann eigentlich auch in der Bedienung jetzt ähnlich arkan waren, wie das eben mit diesen großen Dingern auch war, so mit BIT selber eintippen und kein User in der Face etc. Ich richtig sehe, du hast ja auch mit einer PDP 11 eine Begegnung gehabt.
Eine PDP 1123 einmal, das war so ein Single-User-System mit RTL drauf. Und die PDP 1123 damals hatten wir...
RTL war das Betriebssystem.
Das war das Betriebssystem, ja, auch Digital Equipment. Und mit der 1123, da hatten wir einen Frame-Crepper angeschlossen. Also damit konnte man von der Videokamera Bilder aufnehmen und die in den Rechner digitalisiert verwenden.
Aber nicht in Echtzeit?
Nein, nicht in Echtzeit. Man hat versucht, die Bilder dann möglichst schnell zu verarbeiten. Jetzt waren diese Frame-Crepper damals so konzipiert, dass man die über Register auslesen konnte. Das heißt, ich habe ein XY-Register beschrieben, das hat dem Bildpunkt und der Zeilennummer entsprochen. Und dann habe ich den entsprechenden Grauwert in die CPU bekommen. Das ist natürlich sehr mühsam, wenn man damit jetzt ein ganzes Bild auslesen und verarbeiten wollte. Weil genauso umständlich muss ich die veränderten Pixel- oder Bildelemente ja auch wieder zurückschreiben. Und das war meine Begegnung mit der PDP 1123. Ich habe damals versucht, über Direct Memory Access direkt in den Speicher des Framegrappers reinzukommen. Und zwar musste man da die Memory Management Unit der 1123 ein bisschen umprogrammieren, sodass sie auf andere Speicherbereiche zugreifen konnte. Und dann konnte man einfach einen ganzen Block-Transfer durchführen. Ich konnte also einen ganzen Speicherblock in den Hauptspeicher einlesen oder sogar direkt auf dem Speicher im Framegrapper Veränderungen vornehmen, was natürlich einen immensen Geschwindigkeitsgewinn bedeutet hat, weil ich diesen ganzen Adressierungsmist nicht machen musste, von Adressbit setzen und auslesen und so weiter. Allein, wenn man da ein Histogramm über ein Bild gerechnet hat, also so die Grauwertverteilung übers Bild, das waren Faktoren von 10, 15 an Geschwindigkeit, die man da rausgeholt hat. Und es ging ja immer darum, also ich habe immer in dem Bereich gearbeitet, dass hinter dem Rechner irgendeine Maschine stand, die man damit steuern wollte, sei es so eine Wickelmaschine oder ein Roboter oder was auch immer. Und die müssen ja in gewissen Taktzeiten auch bedient werden. Und diese 1123, damals hatte ich ein Bildverarbeitungssystem geschrieben, womit man die Lambda-Sonden, die in den Autos, in den Katalysatoren verbaut werden, prüfen konnte. Die Lambda-Sonden, das sind kleine Keramikkörper, auf denen mit Platinfarbe, sehr teuer das Zeug, so ein Muster aufgedruckt wird. Und man musste mit einer Kamera überprüfen, ob das Muster richtig ist oder ob die Farbe verlaufen ist. So, und das habe ich mit diesem Framecrapper, mit diesem modifizierten auf der 1123, dann auch relativ schnell hinbekommen. Also man hat dieses kleine Hütchen, das war auf einem Motor, draufgespannt. Und man hat den gedreht und acht Einzelaufnahmen geschossen. Dann wurden diese Einzelaufnahmen verglichen, um zu sagen, okay, die guten ins Körbchen und die schlechten halt weg.
Heute unerlässlich in einer Massenproduktion, solche kamerabasierten...
Das geht heute überwesentlich schneller, aber man konnte damals schon viel machen. Wir haben mit ähnlichen Systemen Kisten ausgeräumt mit dem Roboter und dem Greifer. Das waren zum Beispiel Gehäuse für Winkelschleifer. Die waren in irgendeiner Holzkiste drin. Und man musste jetzt wissen, wo ist denn der höchste Punkt in dem ganzen Stapel, sodass der Roboter hinfährt und von oben die Kiste abräumen konnte. Und das musste so weit gehen, dass zum Schluss auch kein Teil in der Kiste liegen bleibt. Das haben wir mit dem Licht-Schnitt-Verfahren gemacht. Dann ist man mit Schräglicht über diese Kiste drüber gefahren und hat dann die Linienkonturen vermessen mit der Kamera, sodass man genau wusste, da liegt ein höheres Teil und da geht es tiefer. Und dann ist der Roboter dahin gefahren und hat die Kiste von oben nach unten ausgeräumt. Aber das ging halt alles auf Zeit. Bei diesen Lambda-Sonden, kann ich mich erinnern, hatten wir zwei Sekunden Zeit, um eine ganze Sonde zu überprüfen. Und das war eine Höllenzeitvorgabe. Wenn man sich vorstellt, man muss in der Zeit den Motor ansteuern und acht Bilder auswerten mit einer 1123. Das war, glaube ich, auch eine 5 MHz-Kiste. Also da muss man schon ganz schön tricksen. Und das ging eigentlich auch nur so richtig effektiv im Assembler-Code.
PDP ist ja so ein bisschen eins der Frühzeitmodelle, die auch so ein bisschen Hacker-Rom abbekommen hat. Also diese ganze PDP 11-Serie ist ja unter anderem auch eigentlich mit zwei Betriebssystemen verbunden. Einerseits dem VMS-Betriebssystem von DEC, mit dem hast du, glaube ich, auch gearbeitet.
Ja, später, auf der Microwax. Also auf der 1160 gab es das RT11M. Also das war so ein Multi-User-System, RT11. Realtime 11. Das war ein schönes System, also ich habe das gemocht. Und der Computer hier, den wir hatten, eben weil es ein Multi-User-System war, der hat hinten so einen Panel mit lauter seriellen Schnittstellen. Dann haben wir Kabel hier im ganzen Institut rumgezogen, in die einzelnen Büros. Jeder hatte da so ein Terminal stehen mit einer Tastatur. Und das wurde dann zum Rechner runter übertragen. Also da gab es nicht so, dass jeder seinen eigenen PC hatte.
Das waren dann schon diese schicken VT-100-Terminals.
Das waren die VT-100s mit grüner Schrift auf schwarzem Grund.
Der Klassiker eigentlich überhaupt.
Und das war eigentlich damals das Terminal. Das hat man überall gefunden und jeder hat damit gearbeitet. Grafische Oberflächen gab es damals natürlich noch nicht. Und Maus schon auch noch gar nicht dran zu denken. Also, wie gesagt, VT-100 mit ASCII-Sequenzen. Und dann hat man damit seine Ausgaben gemacht.
Ja, später hat ja die PDP-11 euer Beitrag geleistet zur Entwicklung von UNIX. Weil das ja von Königin und so weiter da bei den Bellabs halt so eine Hardware war, die rumstand. Und dann ist da ja auch noch mal ein neues Betriebssystem drauf. Aber du hast viel mit VMS gearbeitet.
Also ich habe nie mit UNIX zu tun gehabt. Ich habe mit VMS gearbeitet und dann später mit Microsoft. Aber niemals mit UNIX.
Bis heute nicht?
Bis heute nicht. Ich habe ein UNIX in Linux zu Hause und verbinde das mit meinem PC. Einfach, ich habe eine Amateurfunkstation und da gibt es einige Programme, die unter Linux ganz gut laufen. Gab es damals, inzwischen gibt es hier unter anderen Betriebssystemen genauso. Und das war für mich ein Grund, mich mal mit Linux zu beschäftigen. Das war ein SUSE Linux 6.0. Und ich habe damit lange rumgekämpft, um überhaupt mal mein Display so hinzubekommen, dass das so ausschaut, wie ich es gerne haben wollte. Aber das kennt, glaube ich, jeder, der sich damit mal auseinandergesetzt hat. Seit heute geht es wohl alles viel einfacher, wenn man da Systeme generiert. Aber das war damals für mich ein Rückschritt gegenüber dem, was ich kenne. Und damit habe ich es gelassen.
Ja, das war damals so ein bisschen die trennenden Welten. Diese UNIX-Welt, die aufkam und dazu halt VMS. Ich meine, wie es geschichtlich aussah.
Ich will das nicht schlecht machen.
Es ist auch interessant, das mal herauszuarbeiten, weil das ist natürlich jetzt schon ein bisschen so ein vergessener Krieg. Wie soll ich sagen, auch dieser Windows-Macintosh-War war ja auch immer so, nimm doch den Mac, der ist ja viel besser. Die anderen waren immer so, hm, aber für mich ist es ja gut genug. Und so ein bisschen, nicht wahr? Und dann ist Windows so davongezogen. Und genauso hatte es sich auch ein bisschen mit UNIX und VMS verhalten. Also alle Leute, die viel mit VMS gearbeitet haben, die haben so ein UNIX immer mit einer gewissen Verachtung angeschaut, weil das einfach so unrund war. Und es war halt immer schon so ein Hackersystem, was seinen Charme hatte, weil irgendwie kriegt man es immer irgendwie hin. Es war sehr einfach gestrickt. Also so ein bisschen mehr der Bazaar. Und die Kathedrale war dann VMS, also ein durchgeplantes System mit Zugriffsrechten und einem ausgefeilten Datei-System.
Genau, und vor allen Dingen, man hat Befehle hingeschrieben und man wusste auch, was der Befehl tut. Wenn ich da hingeschrieben habe, Copy, dann war das... Gut, bei UNIX hieß es noch CP, glaube ich.
Ja, ja, bloß nicht so viele Buchstaben dabei.
Das ist noch ein bisschen naheliegend zu Copy, aber es gibt andere Befehle, die sind schon schwer zu verstehen, dass dahinter steht, was der Rechner dann wirklich damit anfängt. Und von daher waren wir eigentlich VMS. Ich habe das immer gut verstanden. Also die Befehle, die waren mehr oder weniger Klartext, die man hingeschrieben hat. Und das war auch... Wir haben eine Raumfahrtmission gemacht, dann unter VMS auf einer Microwax mit DECnet. Das war so eine Computer-zu-Computer-Verbindung am Anfang. Man konnte also wirklich über Netzwerk Daten austauschen. Und das war alles mehr oder weniger straightforward. Man hat das gestartet und das lief. Und das war klasse. Ich habe das System einfach gemocht. Von daher war das... Also ich habe sehr viel mit RSX11M gearbeitet natürlich.
Die Weiterentwicklung von dem RT11?
Das war eine Weiterentwicklung von dem RT11. Aber wie gesagt schon ein Multi-User- und ich glaube sogar auch Multitasking-System. Nein, nicht Multitasking, ein Multi-User-System. Also es konnten mehrere User auf der Maschine arbeiten. Und der hat dann die Speicherbereiche entsprechend eingeteilt. Wobei das so klingt, als ob der massenhaft Speicher gehabt hätte. Der hatte aber auch nur 128K. Aber damals waren die Programme ja auch viel kleiner, die wir geschrieben hatten. Also mit Assembler schaffen wir ja nicht Megabytes zu schreiben, sondern das geht dann mit ein paar Kilobyte schon ab. Anders, wenn man jetzt heute auf dem Window zum Beispiel Hello World oder was schreiben will und man guckt sich mal den Code an, da steht dann ein Megabyte Exit dahinter, um so eine einfache Zahl oder eine Zeile auf dem Bildschirm auszugeben.
Ja, das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Dieser Zuwachs an Krote und an Datenmengen, was heute das einfachste Programm an Grundanforderungen hat, da fragt man sich, wie diese Computerrevolution überhaupt mal jemals in Wallung kommen könnte. Wenn man damals so ineffizient programmiert hätte, wäre da nie was gegangen.
Das wäre überhaupt nicht gegangen. Die Rechner hätten das gar nicht geschafft. Solche Dinge wie halbdurchsichtige Fenster leisten, die halbtransparenz sind, das hätte die CPU gekillt damals. Die wäre verglüht.
Das wäre gar nicht gegangen.
Vor einigen Jahren, als es so angefangen hat, in Visual Studio zu programmieren, dann habe ich mal im Debugger versucht, den Befehl durchzugehen, den ich da eingegeben hatte, so wie ich das von früher gewöhnt war. Irgendwann landet man in den tiefsten Tiefen des Betriebssystems und man gibt es dann auf. Man kann eigentlich gar nicht dadurch klicken, bis man wieder zur Einsprungadresse zurückkommt. Da werden so viele Routinen aufgerufen, nur um Fenster aufzumachen und Text reinzuschreiben. Es funktioniert. Man nimmt diese Library-Funktion, bindet sie ein und sagt, der Rechner macht das schon. Aber man ist weit, weit weg von dem eigentlichen Verständnis, was läuft denn eigentlich im Rechner ab? Und das ist das, was mir eigentlich Spaß gemacht hat, die ganze Zeit zu verstehen. Was macht der eigentlich, wenn ich den Befehl hinschreibe? Oder warum läuft denn plötzlich mein Rechner viel, viel schneller, wenn ich eine Matrix andersrum abarbeite? Wenn ich Zeilen und Spalte vertausche zum Beispiel, einfach weil der zeilenmäßig orientiert ist, und die Dinge einfach viel schneller adressieren kann, als wenn er immer wieder nachladen muss, weil die Information eben nicht im Cache steht. Und wenn man das weiß, dann kann man auch effektiv programmieren. Also wie gesagt, ich hatte immer mit Echtzeitprogrammierung zu tun. Bei mir ging es immer um Zeit und möglichst schnell den Algorithmus durchzujagen. Und dann muss man sich sehr wohl überlegen, wie liegen denn die Daten im Rechner? Hat er das überhaupt noch im Cache oder nicht? Und wenn er bei jedem Zugriff oder bei jedem Zeilenwechsel den Cache nachladen muss, dann wird das Ding natürlich eh nicht langsam.
Ich meine, die Probleme sind in dem Sinne heute nicht viel anders, auch wenn sie sich in anderen Größenordnungen vielleicht abspielen.
Die sind nach wie vor da, klar.
Aber es ist ja eben dann auch sehr schwer, noch selber Hand anzulegen. Ich fand das vorhin ganz interessant. Warum meinst du, da hättest du ja mal so richtig die CPU gegeben? Hast du das irgendwie noch abrufbar? Ich meine, wie komplex war denn die CPU damals?
Das war...
Also was hat die ausgemacht? Ich erinnere mich noch so aus meiner Anfangszeit, dass eben auch diese einfachen Mikroprozessoren teilweise wirklich hanebüchende Limitierungen hatten, die man sich heute gar nicht mehr vorstellen kann. Also alle Register waren nur 4-Bit groß und so ein Kram.
16-Bit war dann schon eigentlich groß, ein Akku mit 16-Bit?
Ja klar, aber es war ja auch ein ganzer Schrank mit Drehstrom und so.
Also 16-Bit Akku und dann so Adressregister.
Genau, ich wollte mal diese Begriffe so ein bisschen aufspalten, weil man sagt das immer so daher, so Akku und so weiter. Also innerhalb, wenn man jetzt mal in die CPU reinschaut, was sind da damals die Begriffe gewesen, mit denen du da zu tun hattest? Also woraus bestand diese CPU und was war quasi erforderlich, um den Computer zum Laufen zu bringen?
Also der Kern ist, sagen wir mal, der Akkumulator, was letztendlich eine Speicherzelle ist.
Das heißt, da kann man einen Wert vorhalten. Und wenn man sagt, 16-Bit-Computer heißt in dem Moment 16-Bit-Speicherbreite dieses Wertes, nicht 16-Bit der Adressierung des Speicheraums.
Nein, das ist noch mal was anderes.
Weil so viel Speicher hätte man gar nicht zusammen kaufen können.
Also die haben damals gerade mal ihre 32K adressieren können mit den 16-Bit, das war es dann auch. So, und das ist einmal der Kern, ist der Akkumulator. In dem wurden auch die Rechenschritte zum Beispiel durchgeführt. Wenn ich dividieren will, dann shifter ich die Zahl. Oder wenn ich multiplizieren will, dann shifter ich sie nach links rüber. Und diese Schritte wurden in dem Akkumulator durchgeführt. Jetzt muss ich natürlich dafür sorgen, dass ich die Zahl, die ich bearbeiten will, ja auch in den Akku rein bekomme. Das heißt, ich habe einen Adressregister, dem schreibe ich rein. Ich möchte die Zelle 1100 lesen.
Also ein Register ist quasi immer so ein Kurzzeitspeicher.
Es wird ein Speicher. Und da steht jetzt die 1100 drin. Und diese 1100 lege ich auf den Bus, an dem auch das Memory anhängt.
Das heißt, der Wert, der in dem Register ist, wird dann quasi nach außen auf Leitungen gegeben.
Richtig.
Das ist dann der Bus. Diese Leitungen liegen dann auch noch wo an?
Am Speicher vorrangig erstmal. Und dann fühlt sich die Zelle 1100 angesprochen.
Aber die fühlt sich ja nicht selbst angesprochen.
Da gibt es ein Triggersignal, dann ein Read. Das heißt, dann guckt dieses Read-Signal zusammen mit der angelegten Adresse, erzeugt, spricht dann diese Adresse an.
Also Triggersignal heißt eine weitere Leitung, die heißt Read sozusagen. Das geht dann irgendwie an.
Und dann wird aus dem Speicher der Inhalt der Zelle 1100, wenn wir dabei bleiben, wieder auf den Bus zurückgelegt.
Das heißt, es gibt dann eine Logik, die interpretiert die Bits des Datenbusses, also des Adressbusses, Entschuldigung, ausgelöst durch das Einsmachen dieses Reads. Richtig. Und führt es sozusagen auf die richtigen Leitungen, diesen Magnet, also liest die richtigen XY-Koordinaten quasi aus, um dann den richtigen Kern zu lesen und lässt sich quasi von dem dann die Magnetisierung durchgehen.
Die richtigen 16 Kerne, wenn wir mit einem 16-Bit-Rechnen werden. Diese Zeile wird ausgelesen und in den Datenbus gelegt. Und dann gibt es wieder ein Triggersignal, was dann die Daten vom Datenbus entweder in ein Hilfsregister oder direkt in den Akku reinschreibt.
Das, was jetzt von dem Core-Logikbereich ausgelesen wurde aus diesen 16 Kernen, was auf dem Datenbus liegt, liegt dann an den Leitungen wiederum an der eigentlichen CPU an oder an der ALU in dem Moment. Und dann wird wieder eine Kopie erzeugt in dem Akku und dann hat man das ausgelesen.
Genau. Und das ist so der wichtigste Schritt. Ich muss ja immer Daten irgendwie aus dem Speicher holen, die in den Akku bringen. Und jetzt zum Beispiel mit einer anderen Zahl verheiraten. Da gibt es also ein zweites Register, in dem man zum Beispiel die zweite Zahl gespeichert hat. Und mit dem Akku macht man immer diese Multiplikation oder Addition, schiebt die übereinander. Und dann werden sie zusammengezählt.
Wie viele richtige 16-bit-Register hatte diese CPU?
Ich glaube, das waren in der Gegend acht. Ja, ja, ja. Also man konnte dazwischenwärter auch immer wieder ablegen und sagen, ich nehme jetzt dieses Register und veranleite das.
Das waren auch noch mal Kerne.
Nein, das waren keine Kerne. Das waren diskrete Speicher. Oh, frag mich jetzt nicht, wie die realisiert waren.
Der Akku?
Nein, kann ich jetzt nicht sagen. Das waren Registerbausteine. Also wie der es realisiert war, weiß ich nicht.
Aber schon elektronisch jetzt keine LEDs oder so?
Nein, es war kein Klapperatismus. Es war einfach eine Elektronik, die die Werte halten konnte. Das waren, glaube ich, Ladungen, die man gespeichert hat. Letztendlich geht es hier immer nur um Ladung oder 0,1 Wechseln, die man da hin und her schiebt.
Also kleine Kondensatoren, die dann sozusagen aufgeladen wurden.
Und die haben auch relativ kurz nur die Information gehalten. Die mussten immer wieder so ein RIF-Rest kriegen, damit sie wieder... Ja, das waren Kondensatoren, klar. Deshalb haben sie auch den RIF-Rest gebraucht, sodass die immer wieder aufgeladen werden. Wenn die Zahl längere Zeit drin steht und man macht nichts, dann entlädt sich das Ding, und dann ist sie wieder weg. Das waren so ein Kurzzeitspeicher. Und da drinnen mit diesen Dingen, die waren relativ schnell, man konnte schnell drauf zugreifen, und da hat man eben auch die Operationen dann durchführen können.
Und beim Schreiben? Das gleiche Spiel?
Das gleiche Spiel, nur andersrum.
Auf den Datenbus?
Auf den Datenbus, dann die Speicherzelle auf den Adressbus, das Ride-Signal raus, und dann wird es in den Speicher reingelegt.
Das war dann wieder eine separate Leitung sozusagen.
Und im Prinzip ging das genauso auch zu den angeschlossenen Peripheriegeräten. Das war auch nichts anderes. Es war so ein Input-Bus und ein Output-Bus in dem System. Und je nachdem, welches Device ich angesprechen wollte, bin ich auf den entsprechenden Bus gegangen, habe die Adresse angelegt und dann den Datenwert. So hat man Platten beschrieben, Platten ausgelesen, das war immer das Gleiche. Und wie gesagt, aber die CPU oder die ALU, das war dann eine größere Platine, wo sich das Ganze abgespielt hat. Also nicht nur diese paar Register, die da realisiert waren, da ist ja auch noch Elektronik dabei, um Spannung zu halten und so weiter.
Außerdem, ich meine, wenn jetzt ein Programm abgelaufen ist, dann muss ja dieses Programm auch erst mal gelesen werden, liegt im Speicher. Da gibt es dann wahrscheinlich den Instruction Pointer nochmal separat. Also nochmal ein Adressregister, wo drin steht, da ist jetzt der nächste Programmcode. Was ist ja vorhin gesagt, dieser Nano-Code, oder wie heißt das genannt? Micro-Code. Also man programmiert ja eigentlich schon so gegen so ein User-Interface mit irgendwie, addier mal, zieh mal ab, speicher mal ab, liess mal ein. Was ist denn dann die eigentliche Exekutive, die das alles steuert?
Also das ist eine Ablaufelektronik, die eben auf der CPU-Platine realisiert ist. Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel sage, ich möchte subtrahieren, dann ist das ein vorgegebener Ablauf an Micro-Code-Schritten. Also jeder Befehl ist praktisch hinterlegt, wie wird er denn im Micro-Code durchgeführt. Und diese Sequenz läuft dann gnadenlos einfach ab. Also wenn der jetzt im Maschinencode einen ADIR-Befehl sieht, dann sagt er, okay, ich muss zwei Zahlen haben, die hole ich mir erst mal, und dann mache ich die Addition und schreibe das Ergebnis wieder irgendwo hin. Das ist immer ein fest vorgegebener Ablauf. Und so gibt es denn für Division, Multiplikation, das ist so realisiert. Und das alles ist auf dieser CPU-Platine in Form von mehr oder weniger diskreten Bausteinen drin. Und je nachdem, wenn da jetzt ein Befehl im Instruction-Pointer angesprochen ist, dann wird analysiert, wie muss ich diesen Befehl in diese Mikroschritte zerlegen, um den eben entsprechend auszuführen.
Das heißt, man liest quasi diesen ersten Wert an der Stelle im Speicher, schaut sich das an. Das ist dann irgendwie eine 34 und eine 34 bedeutet halt, kopiere den Inhalt vom Akku an irgendeiner Adresse und dann weiß er, aha, da liegt er wahrscheinlich dahinter, dann auch gleich die entsprechenden Adressinformationen, wo es denn jetzt hin soll. Und der Microcode führt dann einfach stursch das aus, aber er tut es halt auch nicht in einem Schritt, sondern gegebenenfalls in mehreren Schritten, das heißt der Takt der CPU erfordert dann pro Instruktion eine variable Anzahl an einzelnen Schritten, je nachdem wie komplex das Ganze ist.
Genau, genau so ist es. Also ich kann nicht sagen, ich brauche so und so viele Mikroschritte, um jeden einzelnen Befehl durchzuführen, sondern das bei jedem Befehl unterschiedlich. Es gibt komplexere Befehle, die brauchen wesentlich mehr Mikroschritte und man konnte die CPU damals im Debug-Mode oder wenn man Fehler gesucht hat, auch in Mikroschritten durchtacken. Also ich konnte hergehen und sagen, ich fange jetzt mal an mit dem Additionsbefehl. Jetzt machen wir mal den ersten Schritt. Und dann konnte man mit dem Oszillographen oder dem Logiktester gucken, welcher Datenwert liegt denn jetzt auf dem Datenbus an? Was liegt er denn auf dem Adressbus an? Wenn das gestimmt hat, sagt man, nächsten Schritt. Dann konnte man nachverfolgen, was macht denn der Speicher damit? Kommen die Daten dort an? Das ist eine ganz andere Ebene. Das kann man sich heute gar nicht mehr vorstellen.
Die Bugging läuft heute einfach auf Instruktionsebene ab.
Aber das war Hardware, die buggen. Da kann man sich heute überhaupt keine Gedanken mehr drum machen. Das ist so wie beim Auto, wo man immer sieht, wo der Motor ist. Da ist eine Decke drüber. Wenn ich heute einen Computer kaufe, bin ich weit weg von Mikrograt.
Das ist wie auch schon bei ASCII und den anderen Beispielen, die wir gehabt haben. Die Sprache ist letztlich die gleiche geblieben. Nur die Geschwindigkeit hat zugenommen. Die Dinge sind immer kleiner geworden, sodass man da nicht mehr so richtig anfassen kann. Aber das Prinzip ist nach wie vor identisch.
Die Dinge müssen heute auch noch ihre Daten aus dem Speicher über den Cache in die CPU reinbringen.
Und es gibt den Akku und den Datenbussen, den Adressbussen, alles noch da.
Und es gibt auch diese ganzen Register, Instruction-Counter und so weiter. Ohne das funktioniert kein Rechner. Das war nur damals halt anschaulich im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Man konnte es angucken.
Also war der Z80 dein erster Mikroprozessor?
Ja, das war Z80.
Das war dann auch schon wieder so ein Schock?
Ja, das war einfach so ein Ding. Der soll das jetzt alles machen, was vorher in so einem Kleiderschrank Platz hatte. Aber man war ja lernfähig. Man hat sich also ganz schnell überzeugen lassen, die sind ja noch schneller und eigentlich fast besser noch. Und das war ja das Defrapierende, dass die Dinge, obwohl sie so klein waren, eigentlich in den damaligen Verhältnissen riesen Rechenleistungen drin hatten. Wir haben eine ganze Raumfahrtmission mit dem Roboter mit dem 8086 geflogen. Zusammen mit dem 8087 als Co-Prozessor, also als Floating-Point-Unit. Und das war 1993. Und die Entwicklung hat mal 1989 etwa angefangen.
1993, aber da war der Prozessor auch schon zehn Jahre alt.
Ja, ja. Aber okay, das muss ich dazu sagen, das war eine Raumfahrtmission. Und da kann man natürlich nicht die neuesten Rechner nehmen, weil wahrscheinlich traut man denen nicht, dass die da oben funktionieren. Ja, wie ein gutes Steak. Obwohl man eigentlich manche Sachen fliegen kann, wo man eigentlich gar nicht dran denkt, dass die im Weltraum überleben. Aber die überleben dann doch. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Aber diese 8086, das waren fünf Megahertz-Rechner. Und mit, ich glaube, acht Megabyte Speicher dran, da haben wir eigentlich ganz komplexe Aufgaben damals mit dem Roboter ausgeführt, während einer Mission im Shuttle von der Erde aus. Und das war eigentlich schon frappierend, dass man so etwas Komplexes auf so einem kleinen Chip plötzlich erledigen konnte. Das war eigentlich schon eine Riesenleistung. Und das dann in Verbindung mit einer Microwax an der Bodenstation. Microwax war die Weiterentwicklung eigentlich von Digital Equipment. Die hat eine deutlich höhere Rechenleistung als die PDP 1160, die wir vorher hatten, oder auf jeden Fall viel mehr noch als die 1123. Und das Problem war nur, dass die Zahlendarstellung, also wir hatten das Programm an der Bodenstation lief auf einer Microwax und am Bordsystem im Space Shuttle lief das Gegenstück auf einem 8086, auf einem Intel-Prozessor. Und die Zahlendarstellung von Intel und Microwax haben sich im Exponenten unterschieden. Das heißt, man kann die Real-Zahlen nicht einfach von A nach B schicken und der andere sagt, er hat das eine 1.
Das ist dann eine andere Darstellung der Gleitkommazahlen innerhalb des Computers, innerhalb der CPU selbst.
Ja, richtig. Es gibt ja da verschiedene Darstellungsformate. Und das Problem war, dass wir alle Zahlen dann auch umrechnen mussten. Also wenn wir jetzt Zahlen vom Shuttle oben empfangen haben auf der Microwax, dann hatte ich eine Routine geschrieben, Intel to VAX und VAX to Intel. Und die hat dann erstmal die Zahlen so hingebügelt, dass der andere versteht, was gemeint ist. Also das war wirklich, wie man so schön sagt, Knochenarbeit. Es gab nichts, wo man sagen konnte, ich greife da in die Kiste und nehme irgendwas und das funktioniert. So ähnlich wie Host to Net und Net to Host. Wenn ich jetzt Daten übers Netzwerk schicke, das gab es damals nicht. Bei dem Zahlenformat war das sowas ähnlich, das musste man selber schreiben. Und da wühlt man dann wirklich in den tiefsten Ebenen des Rechners rum.
Der Babelfisch. Ich glaube über das Projekt selber, da brauchen wir jetzt gar nicht so viele Worte zu verlieren. Wer Lust hat, da mal diese Robotik-Aspekte nochmal nachzuhören, gibt es bei Raumzeit, Ausgabe 14. Robotik in der Raumfahrt. Ja, das war so ein bisschen schon bei den 80er Jahren angekommen. Das ist ja dann eigentlich auch, soll ich sagen, kulturell hat sich ja dann doch wirklich einiges geändert. Das war also vorher noch der Spaß von ein paar privilegierten Akademikern, die eben die passende Garage und den Drehstromanschluss auch zur Verfügung hatten. Es gibt ja auch so eine legendäre Hacker-Geschichte rund um Karl Koch, der damals sich ja dann auch irgendwie in Jülich noch so eine alte PDP gezogen hat. Dann haben sie halt auch erst vor Ort festgestellt, so oh Scheiße, warum man ja Drehstrom um das Ding wurzen läuft. Hat natürlich in der ersten Begeisterung keiner daran gedacht, dass da so noch mal so ein Technologiesprung gemacht wurde. Aber dann hat sich ja dann schnell so eine Kultur angeschlossen. Also Hacker-Szene ist da eigentlich auch nur ein Ausriss davon, international. Die ganze Softwareindustrie, die sich damals ja eigentlich erst herausgebildet hat und auch erst hat herausbilden können, als es ja mal universelle Systeme gab. Wir haben ja gerade gesagt, man war zwar irgendwie Computertechniker in den 70ern, aber das setzte eben voraus, dass man eigentlich mit jedem Rechner das einmal eins immer wieder noch mal von links nach rechts und von oben nach unten lesen musste auf einmal, während es überhaupt keine allgemeinen Plattformen gab. Das setzte sich dann eben, ich glaube, das erste, was überhaupt so den Anspruch hatte, also wenn man jetzt mal von, VMS war ja auch eigentlich eher so eine Insel, die sich nur in der Deckwelt abspielte. Aber ich glaube, das erste, was so halbwegs übergreifend war, war nämlich genau mit dem Z80 das CPM-System. Es gab dann viele Hersteller, die irgendwie CPM verwendet hatten. War das bei euch irgendwie auch nochmal Thema?
Ja, haben wir auch. Mit CPM haben wir auch ziemlich viel gemacht, ja.
Das war das erste System, das dann wiederum Prozessorspezifisch war. Auch das gibt ja heutzutage immer noch große Abhängigkeiten. Aber im Prinzip werden Betriebssysteme heute ja nicht mehr für einen Prozessor geschrieben.
Richtig.
Also meistens zumindest nicht. Und CPM war, glaube ich, das erste Ding, was überhaupt auch erstmal eine Plattform gemacht hat. Der Rest ist so ein bisschen Geschichte.
Ja, das waren mehr oder weniger Inseln, was man vorher hatte. Also diese ganze Deckwelt, in der ich mehr oder weniger groß geworden bin. Das war alles verwandte Betriebssysteme. Wenn man RSX11m beherrscht hatte, dann ist der Umstieg zum Beispiel nach VMS nicht sehr schwer gefallen. Das war ziemlich gleich. Man hatte Overlay Description Language, das war so ein Trick, um mit begrenztem Speicherraum auszukommen. Also wir haben Echtzeitprogramme geschrieben, die eigentlich nicht in den Speicher reingepasst hätten, den der Rechner zur Verfügung stellt. Jetzt hat man das so gelöst, dass man einen kleinen Programmteil, einen Residententeil geschrieben hat, auf dem lief im Prinzip das User Interface. Ich habe eine Maske auf dem VT-100 ausgegeben und gefragt, was willst du eigentlich machen? Dann hat der Bediener eingegeben, ich will das und das Programm starten. Dann hat der Rechner diesen Echtzeitteil von der Festplatte nachgeladen in den Speicher und hat ihn ausgeführt, solange bis das beendet wurde und dann konnte man wieder was anderes nachladen, also einen anderen Betrieb. Und somit konnte man so viele Echtzeitmodule, wie wir eben auf der Platte Platz hatten, nacheinander in den Speicher laden, also wohlgemerkt nacheinander. Das war ja gerade das Prinzip, dass man ein sehr komplexes Programm schreiben konnte, mit ganz unterschiedlichen Echtzeitprogrammbetriebsarten, aber die alle von einem Interface aus starten konnten. Das war ein Programm, für den Benutzer war das ein Programm, was aber in viele kleine Scheibchen zerteilt war. Das war das ODL, das war auch eine Entwicklung von Digital Equipment, Overlay Description Language, und ich habe das geliebt, damit zu arbeiten.
Im Prinzip die Vorwegnahme von virtuellem Speicher, Paging und solchen Technologien, die dann später in die Betriebssysteme kamen. Wie komme ich klar, mit Speicher, der nicht da ist?
Ja, genau. Das war auch mein erster privater PC. Was hat er? 640K, glaube ich, haben die Dinge gehabt. Auf dem Mainboard drauf, die ersten, die man da kaufen konnte. Da war ich ganz stolz, mit einer Megabyte Festplatte. Das war so mein erster PC für zu Hause.
Schon mit 640K installiert?
Ja, die waren zu Hause. Doch, die Wanne hatte schon 640K. Ich habe mich immer gewundert, warum das so wenig ist.
Mehr als 640K war erst mal nicht laut Bill Gates, mit dem er immer in den Mund geschoben. Ich glaube, so direkt hat er es nicht gesagt.
Damit kann man alles erledigen.
Selbst wenn er es nicht gesagt hat, ich glaube, das kriegt ihr nie von der Erde gefilmt, dass es nicht unterstellt wird. Und da endet dann in gewisser Hinsicht die Reise der 70er?
Ja, klar. Das war eine interessante Zeit und auch eine Zeit, an der man ständig am Lernen war. Man hat ständig irgendwas Neues dazubekommen. Es gab dann, wie gesagt, ich habe vorhin erzählt, Kamerainterfaces, die man anschließen konnte. Wir haben verschiedene serielle Datenübertragungsprotokolle ausprobiert, um andere Peripheriegeräte anzusprechen. Oder ich habe mal einen Trecker gebaut, der in der Lage war, aus einem Videobild Objekte zu verfolgen, die sich darin bewegt haben. Das war auch über einen DMR-Kanal eine eigene Hardware, die ich damals gebaut habe, um Hell-Dunkel-Übergänge im Bild zu detektieren. Und diese Übergänge in Form von Zeilennummer und Bildpunktnummer an den Rechner übergeben, sodass man im Rechner damit dann wieder rekonstruieren konnte, wo ist denn ein Objekt im Bild und welche Form hat dieses Objekt. Damit konnte man Objekterkennung betreiben. Das heißt, man hat wirklich mit einer Kamera verschiedene Objekte, die man dem Rechner vorher mal gezeigt hat, wiedererkennen können. Das war alles mehr oder weniger Bastelarbeit. Man konnte es nicht kaufen. Man musste das selber programmieren und selber zusammenlöten zum Großteil.
Im Prinzip kommt die Zeit aber eigentlich wieder. Wenn man heutzutage auf einem ähnlichen Level einsteigen möchte, empfiehlt sich die Embedded-Programmierungen, diese ganzen Client-Systeme. Arduino, wobei die jetzt in ihren neuesten Generationen auch schon wieder so mächtig geworden sind durch die Weiterentwicklung, insbesondere der ARM-CPU, dass man da auch schon wieder ganz andere Möglichkeiten hat. Aber eben mit diesen kleinsten Prozessoren, vor allem diesen PICs, die ja selber noch extrem limitiert waren, die man eigentlich auch in Assembler programmieren kann, nicht unbedingt muss. Aber das wäre in gewisser Hinsicht dann auch mal so aus meiner Sicht eine Empfehlung für jeden, der jetzt hier so ein bisschen Blut geleckt hat. Man kann das gar nicht häufig genug betonen, wenn man wirklich das mit den Computern verstehen will, dann ist einfach gerade, deswegen mich auch auf diese CPU-Sachen nochmal eingegangen, also diese ganz grundlegenden Vorgänge mit Instruktionssätzen etc., wenn man das irgendwie mal so nackt an der blutigen Kante gespürt hat, dann hat man einfach auch mehr Aha.
Man muss es auch mal selber gemacht haben. Man muss mal selber versucht haben, zum Beispiel in Assembler was zu programmieren oder eine Interrupt-Routine zu stricken, die möglichst schnell auf einen Interrupt reagiert und dann mit dem Reti wieder zurückspringt in die Hauptroutine. Das alles mal zu verstehen, dass ich in dem Moment, wenn ich einen Programmablauf unterbreche durch einen Interrupt, da muss ich ja erstmal alle Register sichern, sonst macht er nachher, wenn er zurückgeht, ja nur noch Unfug. Das heißt, ich muss einmal verstehen, was passiert eigentlich dabei, wenn ich das tue. Und wenn man das einmal intus hat oder dieses Mal selber programmiert hat, dann versteht man auch, wo die Grenzen von Computern sind. Also ich kann nicht beliebig schnelle Interrupts auf den Rechner loslassen, dann ist er nur noch beschäftigt mit Registerretten und kann eigentlich in der Interrupt-Routine selber nicht mehr allzu viel tun. Und diese ganze Logik, die kann man eigentlich am besten verstehen, wenn man es mal an einem einfachen Beispiel mal selber gemacht hat.
Und vor allem kann man danach echt schnell einen Code schreiben.
Ich habe eigentlich nie Programme geschrieben, bei denen es nicht drauf ankam, wie schnell sie denn fertig werden. Wenn ich mich jetzt an den Computer setze und programmiere jetzt irgendeinen Algorithmus, wobei mir das Ergebnis dann möglichst schnell halt auf dem Bildschirm erscheinen soll, aber es hängt nichts davon ab, wenn diese Zeit eben nicht eingehalten wird, dann kann ich das mit jeder Methode irgendwie machen. Das funktioniert dann schon. Wenn ich mich nicht vertue und die Gleichung richtig eintippe, dann kommt auch das Richtige raus. Das Problem ist aber, wenn ich das zum Beispiel in einem Millisekunden- oder halben Millisekunden-Takt an eine Hardware, die draußen am Rechner hängt, rausgeben will. Und dann fängt die Knochenarbeit an. Wenn ich dann feststelle, ich bin ein paar Mikrosekunden zu langsam oder ich muss überprüfen, schaffe ich es denn in meiner Zeitschleife überhaupt, das Problem durchzurechnen. Wenn nicht, muss ich mir Alternativen überlegen.
Was mir gerade klar wird, wo du das sagst, ist ja, dass eigentlich damals, als du angefangen hast, das war ja eigentlich die Frühzeit der Robotik, der Steuerung, das, was dich ja eigentlich auch in den letzten 20, 30 Jahren so in Betrieb gehalten hat. Und wenn man sich jetzt anschaut, was eben für Systeme realisiert werden mit diesen kleinen Arduino-Plattformen etc., ist da auch extrem viel Robotik drin. Das ist ja geradezu das optimale Einstiegsprogramm, weil da kommt dann auch diese Echtzeitanforderung gleich wieder ran. Weil der Arm dann muss dann irgendwie auch schnell genug sein und darf auch nicht zu weit laufen. Und wenn man nicht rechtzeitig irgendwas dediktiert und ausgewertet hat, läuft er halt gegen die Wand etc. Das sind ja eigentlich dieselben Sachen.
Oder ich habe im Handy irgendeinen Prozessor drin, der zu langsam ist, dann klingt die Sprache halt nicht besonders gut.
In diesem Sinne kann man eigentlich nur empfehlen, baut mehr Roboter.
Ja, oder nehmt euch irgendeinen Rechner und bastelt mal selber was zusammen.
Okay Klaus, ich glaube, das war es hier, unsere Reise durch die 70er.
Zeitschnell vergangen.
Ja, ist sie. Sowohl die 70er als auch die Zeit hier beim Podcast. Vielen Dank.
Gerne.
Ja, und vielen Dank hier fürs Zuhören bei CAE. Hier geht es bald wieder weiter.